thouars 20 je me disais l'autre jour il
ya des trucs qu'on les a soulevé à
longueur de journée on se rend même pas
compte à quel point ils sont importants
aubin c'est gentil mais je suis habitué
tréand l'ombre non mais je parlais des
crottes de nez là
vous en avez tous déjà roulé une entre
vos doigts mais est-ce que vous êtes
seulement demandé d'où elle venait
vraiment et à quoi il servait au mieux
vous les mépriser au pire vous les
détestez depuis qu'elle vous ont gâché
un rendez-vous en faisant une apparition
a prévu et pourtant le creux de données
nous veulent du bien
si si si si si je vous jure bon laissez
moi vous expliquer je vous apprends rien
l'air qu'on respire il est pas propre et
bien notre corps déploie des trésors
d'ingéniosité pour le nettoyer avant
qu'ils atteignent nos précieux ça se
fait tout le long des voies
respiratoires mais ça commence dans le
nez qui humidifie qui réchauffe et
surtout qui dépoussière l'air con
inscrire comment grâce à deux
dispositifs plus ou moins sophistiquées
les poils du nez d'abord qui joue le
rôle d'un filtre chargé d'empêcher les
particules d'entrée une soirée d'un papa
papa de pollen pas de poussière se
dégage
et puis elle met cus le mucus et un
liquide gluant qui est sécrétée par la
muqueuse des fosses nasales et qui est
chargé d'emprisonner les impuretés et de
les garder bien au chaud
un peu comme heures un peu comme du
papier tue-mouche en fait le mucus
détruit une partie des cochonneries
filtrés par le nez mais les gros morceau
reste coincé dans les narines ensuite il
sèche et ils deviennent ce qu'on appelle
des crottes de nez en temps normal le
mérite et transparent mais il peut
prendre la couleur des particules qui
l'absorbent et en cas d'infection des
globules blancs qu'on appelle
neutrophiles s'attaque aux germes grâce
à des enzymes qui contiennent du fer et
sait se faire qui est contenu dans les
déchets qui sont ensuite rejetés lui
donne cette couleur verte
traditionnellement associées aux crottes
de nez et à la morgue à tiens au passage
la mort c'est le nom d'une maladie
infectieuse qui touche les chevaux et
les ânes et transmissible à l'homme elle
a quasiment disparu et c'est tant mieux
parce qu'elle est mort camus
vous voyez qu'on est loin des
psychiatres direction là le vrai monde
c'est long
alors vente et ou pas non non ça va pas
trop là c'est l'histoire des chevaux la
mort tout ça non c'est juste les crottes
de l'unfpa trois manches et c'est ça ok
j'imagine que renault n'est pas le seul
à être angoissé à ce sujet alors on va
faire un petit point culinaire sachez
que lemieux qui s'est composé de 95 à 97
% d'eau le reste étant des ions comme le
sodium par exemple c'est pour ça que
c'est sale et il contient aussi des
substances inoffensives comme des
protéines des lipides et en réalité on
en avale à longueur de journée sans s'en
rendre compte parce que les fosses
nasales en produits jusqu'à un litre par
jour qui coule dans l'arrière gorge
avant de finir dans l'estomac et d'être
digérés comme un vulgaire entre donc le
multisons soi n'est pas toxique
alors si vous avez un petit creux et que
vous êtes dans un bar tos pas les
cacahuètes
vous pouvez y aller d'autant plus que
d'autant plus qu'en réalité du mucus
plein de poussière vous en aval est
aussi un autre celui qui vient d'en bas
et oui parce que tu n'es jusqu'au fin
fond jaune roches les parois de votre
appareil respiratoire sont tapissés par
deux types de cellules
laissez lui la nuque us et d'autres
qu'on appelle cellule à signer libre
at-il bon alors si vos cellules ont des
cibles vibratiles c'est pas mon affaire
sexuelle lancées pour fabriquer un
véritable tapis roulant pour le mucus
les cellules à cils vibratiles ça
ressemble à ça bon si l'idée d'avoir des
anémones de mer dans la trachée s'avoue
traumatise on va essayer autre chose
imaginez une tribune dans un stade dans
laquelle tout le monde portait bonnet
ridicule maintenant imaginez que tout ce
petit monde fait la ola
bah voilà vous avez à peu près le
mouvement de votre vie alors vous allez
me demander mais à quoi ça sert à quoi
ça sert à ça suffit romain maintenant et
bien ce mouvement ininterrompu forment
un véritable escalators à mucus qui
raccompagne les sécrétions et les
particules indésirables qu'elles
contiennent jusqu'à l'arrière gorge où
elles sont avalés une crash et c'est
comme on aime attention la fumée de
cigarette
en plus de contenir des substances
cancérigènes c'est pas l'ami de vos
cellules à cils vibratiles à court terme
elle et paralyse et à long terme elle
les tue du coup les sécrétions de plus
en plus de mal à rejoindre la sortie et
elle stagne dans la trachée ce qui
stagne ça a tendance à s'infecter pour
ça que les fumeurs et tous et ils
crachent des trucs salle où les avals
c'est comme on aime sachez aussi qu'en
cas de maladie votre corps malin comme
il est il se rend bien compte qu'il va
avoir un maximum de germes à évacuer bon
qu'il augmente sa production news les
mecs vont venir les lie sort vedette
leurs potes c'est pour ça que dans ces
cas là on a le nez qui coule et la toux
grasse voilà j'espère que vous êtes
réconcilie avec votre ordonnée vous
voyez bien qu'elles sont sympas et
dernière chose vos poils du nez ils sont
cools aussi vous avez vu alors si
vraiment des dreadlocks qui nous sortent
des naseaux couper les haras mais elle
n'est pas coupé ceux qui sont à
l'intérieur vous en avez besoin
dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui vous
pouvez me poser vos questions sur la
santé du corps humain dans les
commentaires n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner et à la semaine prochaine
comme d'hab